salut à tous ce succès d'hamilton acier
qu'on lui parle de los angeles où il y
eu la chance hier de gagner un grammy
award pour la production de l'album que
j'ai fait pour angélique kidjo
pourquoi le ps est musicalement donc je
voulais en dédier un énorme morceau à la
martinique à laquelle je dois tant on a
family à cette culture qui m'a nourri
qui m'a enrichi et qui m'a permis aux
coûts dans ses albums se faire peur aux
couvertures éléments que je peux
utiliser
il ya eu un enfant entendre à ce moment
j'aime proche de vous toujours dans ma
tête je vais faire un grand discours
l'uci à l'autre nos minimes hier soir
qui était le groupe peut compter avec la
grèce champion poids de nos peines mais
un magnifique projet aussi alors bravo à
vue pour ce projet à bientôt lamartine